it's my pleasure to introduce uh Dr
Sarah Walker here today
um uh Dr Walker is a senior lecturer at
the school of Economics at the
University of New South Wales in Sydney
Australia I'm really delighted that she
has agreed to get up early so she can
have part of her day overlap with ours
and present in our seminar this
afternoon
um uh Sarah is a really
um very talented emerging scholar in the
fields of development economics
environmental economics economic history
um sort of her work centers on a lot of
really interesting questions related to
institutions culture and also sort of
development the environment
Sarah's work has won sort of several
honors and awards so in 2020 the Paul
Burke award for early career research
for the from The Academy of social
sciences in Australia she's also a
winner of the discovery early career
research award from the Australian
research Council and today she's going
to be sharing some of her really
fascinating work with us that she's done
on Refugee communities in Kenya I will
pass it over to Sarah for
um
uh
her talk she's asked she's allowed
interruptions throughout sort of an econ
style talk so if you have any questions
you know please raise your hand or use
the chat feature if you use the chat
feature I will sort of find a nice time
to interject and ask the questions that
way she doesn't have to monitor the chat
herself without further Ado I'll pass it
over to Sarah for for the talk
great thank you so much thank you so
much Emily thank you so much to the to
the Center for inviting me this is a
real pleasure and and I'm excited to
share this work with you
um this is actually kind of an older
project at this point
um this is first of all joint work with
Jennifer Alex Garcia who is an economist
at Oregon State University and
incidentally is also the former PhD
advisor to myself and to Emily so we
share a very common Bond there
um and it's also joint work with Ann
Bartlett who's a sociologist at
University of New South Wales here in
Sydney so it's truly an
interdisciplinary
um
uh set of work and I'm I'm delighted to
share this with an interdisciplinary
audience
so you know we actually collected the
the data for this project in 2015 and
I'm going to present today to you two
papers actually that have already been
published so one in 2018 and one in in
2019
um which is a little bit awkward I must
say for an economist because we're
really used to presenting work in
progress and sort of getting feedback
there
um but nonetheless you know I I think
it's important work and and I hope you
do as well and I'm still interested
obviously in your comments and and
having a discussion around this so
thanks for that
um so the motivation for this work is is
obviously it's no secret to the people
in this room that the numbers of
forcibly displaced people are at an
all-time high so when you look at the
most recent data coming out from unhcr
in 2022 this stands at 103 million
displaced people currently 32.5 million
of whom are refugees and actually as I
Was preparing for this seminar I went
back to these slides that I made a few
years ago when we were when it was still
a work in progress and at that time the
data from unhcr in 2016 was 65 million
displaced people and about
22.5 million refugees so you can see
even in these you know six years uh the
numbers have skyrocketed and they're
only going to continue to rise as people
fully affected regions and seek Asylum
internationally
you know something that's
um that I think we also know about this
situation with refugees is that many
refugees are living in permanent
settlements so they're living in camps
um the best data I could that I could
come across is still from 2015 when we
were collecting our data so about 41
percent of refugees live in camps that
have been in place for over five years
these are long-term retracted situations
and there are seven settlements
worldwide with populations over 80 000
people so these are like cities these
are small cities sometimes large cities
depending on which Camp you're looking
at so these camps are you know the
largest Camp was in Bangladesh with over
700 000 refugees living there
um we're going to look at a camp in
Kenya Kenya has a couple of very large
camps with populations over a hundred
and eighty thousand people
um other places include Jordan
Uganda and Sudan
so you know one of the the main features
of of the refugee situation that I like
to highlight is that you know most
refugees 83 percent of refugees are
actually living in low or middle income
countries and you know in in high income
countries like the us or Australia where
I'm living or especially in Europe you
know a lot of the debate in policy is
coming around you know is focused on
well how is this impacting us and high
income countries but one thing I like to
highlight is that the majority of
refugees are living in in low and middle
income countries that already are not in
the best position to host refugees
financially but nonetheless they do
um the other
statistic I'd like to highlight is that
a large percentage 69 percent of
refugees come from just five countries
so as we know there's ongoing crises in
Syria Venezuela Afghanistan South Sudan
Myanmar which is only increasing we're
going to focus on the count a particular
camp in Kenya which is largely home to
South Sudanese refugees who've been
there for now over 30 years
so the first question we asked with this
project was you know how do refugee
camps impact host communities you know
there's a there's a large debate around
hosting displaced people it's a very
heated debate but especially at the time
we were conducting this work the
empirical evidence was very sparse I
think in recent years there's been a a
large contribution to the literature and
and I think people in the room probably
know more about the more recent work
than I do and I'd love to hear what you
have to say but you know it's it's kind
of an empirical question how do refugee
camps impact host communities and this
is really important for policy making
because especially at the time we were
conducting our field work the Kenyan
government was on the verge of shutting
down camps and it you know it was
important to to understand what what are
the impacts of these camps before we
throw the baby out with the bath water
um you know some of these concerns are
not misplaced there's fear of labor
labor market competition
um but there's also potential benefits
from hosting refugees including
stimulating demand filling labor market
gaps
um Innovation an exchange of knowledge
so we explore a specific case of
long-run encampment in a place called
kakuma Kenya which is in the
Northwestern region of Kenya on the
border of South Sudan and this Camp has
been in existence since 1992.
and we will explore not only when we
look at sort of the average of economic
impacts so that's also important to
highlight there's a lot of other impacts
that you know that are relevant for
policy but as a primarily an economist
uh what we're studying here are the
economic impacts um and then we want to
explore relevant channels you know if we
do find any impacts
the second question we asked was well
how are refugees surviving so largely in
most refugee camps countries are
practicing a policy of what they call
enclosure so refugees can't really leave
the camp they can't work outside of the
camps which means they have to live off
predominantly of food Aid or internal
Camp economy so one of the things I'll
show you today is that there's a
flourishing economy within the camp
itself or they and or they live off of
remittances from relatives who are
either living in the country that was
fled or living elsewhere in the world
maybe in higher income countries
um and so what happened this is this
second question sort of just landed in
our laps by happenstance so when we were
in the camp in 2015 collecting the data
for the first question
um there was a sort of an what we'd call
a natural experiment that occurred where
one channel of remittances was
completely cut off and we were able to
measure you know what happens when this
channel is shut down so you can imagine
you know that obviously there would be
impacts on Refugee households that use
this form of remittances but also if
there are interlinkages economically
between the host and the refugee
Community uh there could also be you
know externalities or flow-on effects to
to the host community and so we'll look
at that also
so the context of our study uh takes
place in Kenya which obviously shares a
border with some highly impacted regions
Refugee sending regions such as South
Sudan Somalia now Ethiopia
um and we are focusing I'm not sure if
you can see my cursor but in the very
northwest corner of Kenya on the border
of South Sudan is a region called
turkana
and we're looking specifically at a camp
basically right about there called
kakuma
so
um something to know about turkana is
that it's home to the turkana people and
the turkana people are a group of
semi-nomadic pastoralists who are
largely disengaged with a formal economy
and certainly in the early 90s we're
disengaged with with a formal economy
and they mostly heard cattle for a
living so they'll set up semi-permanent
residences where they practice a little
maybe a little bit of horticulture
mostly women are are practicing a little
bit of horticulture and the men
predominantly are hurting cattle they'll
go out for long periods of time to graze
their cattle and they'll come back and
then maybe they pick up and move to
another settlement
uh something to note about turkana is
that it is extremely poor and isolated
so this data comes from the 2005 census
um and that was the most recent data we
had at the time of publication I just
checked the stats from the 2018 census
the other day
um and not much has changed so I know
something to note is that even when you
you know Kenra Kenya is a low low and
middle income country itself but when
you compare turkana to the rest of Kenya
it's even poorer so 94 I think now it's
around 90 of households living in
turkana are below the poverty line
um household sizes are larger than they
are even in other rural parts of Kenya
School attendance is extremely low that
has not changed much in the past almost
20 years
um and households rely far less on
farming than the rest of of Kenyan
households that's largely because of the
area of turkana is very arid it's dry I
showed you the picture experience has a
very scrubby
um that of foliage the soil is not great
and you know for one of those reasons
um for some of those reasons households
largely rely on cattle herding for a
living so you can see you know the
average number number of cattle goats
sheep owned by turkana households are is
much larger than than household than
other parts of Kenya
foreign
and protracted uh conflict in South
Sudan intensified
and 7 000 South Sudanese mostly young
boys walked from South Sudan across into
Ethiopia temporarily and over the Border
in into Kenya and these you know have
these these boys have been referred to
as the lost boys and you know there's a
lot that's been written about them
if you've if you haven't read the book
what is the what by Dave Eggers uh it's
a fantastic story true story of one of
these boys who who fled South Sudan and
ultimately ended up in the United States
but it gives a really uh intimate
portrayal of of what these boys endured
in their Journey
um so in 1991 around 7 000 young boys
walked into Kenya and settled actually
just over the Border in a town called
lokichogio and by the following year
more and more people had started to to
come over the border and um
the government of Kenya agreed to set up
a refugee camp in the town of kakuma
which at the time had a population of
less than six thousand by the following
year 35
000 people were living in the camp and
essentially overnight kakuma became a
city
and by 2015 at the time when we were
conducting our field work over a hundred
and eighty thousand refugees were living
in in kokuma refugee camp coming mostly
from South Sudan but from from other
areas as well including Somalia the DRC
Ethiopia and Darfur
and today kakuma is one of the longest
standing refugee camps
um and one of the largest in the world
so here's an aerial shot of kakuma uh it
is situated between two rivers that are
mostly dry but you know in the Rainy
Seasons they tend to flood and it
consists of semi-permanent structures
um
but you know over time uh uh an economy
has developed I mean it's essentially a
city now and there's flourishing markets
so this is a picture of one of the
Central Markets in in the camp
um this is Franco's hotel which is a
delicious Ethiopian restaurant where we
would often meet with our team for lunch
and debriefings but there's all kinds of
markets and businesses that operate
within the camp restaurants you know
little shops tailors it's really a
flourishing economy and there's a lot of
exchange which not only among the
refugees but also among the host
population so in a lot so and our
colleague is a sociologist she's a
qualitative researcher she did a lot of
semi-structured interviews with people
in in a lot of these qualitative
interviews it became clear that there's
just a very strong link between the host
and the refugee economy so many uh of
the turkana people use the refugee the
markets in the camp as their main
markets there's also schools and
hospitals that are accessible to both
the refugee and the host population
within the camp
sorry Sarah one question uh
are the people in in the refugee camp
able to go and work outside or to work
in general and if not I mean what means
do they use I mean what currency do they
use at that point in order to to get
many I don't know goods and services
that have developed inside this can yeah
so something thank you for that question
first just to answer quickly no so
kakuma practices Kenya practices a
policy of uh and you know full
encampment so they are not refugees are
not allowed to work outside of the camp
um which means that they rely
predominantly on on the food Aid that's
given to them by the by unhcr which
consists mostly of flour oil beans and
rice which they get you know
depending on how large their household
is
um they get a once a month a set amount
um but something to note is actually
that uh and this is specific to the K I
think this is specific to kakum I'm sure
it's true in other camps but I do want
to highlight that the refugees that are
coming into the camp
relatively speaking or wealthier than
the turkana people so they're coming
with more human capital they're also
coming with more capital and they have
links to people outside of the camp that
send them remittances and so that's what
you'll see us talk about in sort of the
second part of the paper but in the
meantime if they can get enough Capital
to for instance set up a shop a lot of
refugees uh have created their own
um you know their own businesses and are
living off of that if they can or
remittances or in the worst of
circumstances just the you know the food
Aid that is given to them they can also
get employed by unhcr as translators or
as teachers or as medical workers to the
extent that they have
um you know the training and now because
the camp has been there for so long
there's a generation of people who have
adults who have grown up who were either
born in the camp or moved there at a
very young age and you know went to
school there and are now you know
essentially living in the campus if it's
their hometown
um so when we think about the possible
ways in which hosting refugees could
affect the local economy there are a
couple of different you know the the
predictions are not clear up front so
the effects could operate through many
different channels the first is a labor
market channel so one of the I think the
primary concerns we hear in higher
income countries is what what's going to
happen when refugees come so our labor
markets are these going to depress wages
and you know as long as the locals are
employed in the same Market that
refugees are trying to get jobs in this
could depress wages
um on the other hand if the ngos that
are setting up these refugee camps uh
demand labor and skills that the local
population has this could increase wages
through Labor demand
another way that refugee camps could
impact the local economies through
competition with Aid related Goods so to
the extent that unhcr and the wfp are
are pushing a whole
increased supply of goods into the
market if there are producers locally
who are also producing these Goods that
competition you know that's going to
depress the price first of all the
increase in Supply will depress the
price if you're a producer that's going
to hurt you but if you're a consumer
that's if you're a net consumer that's
going to help you because now you're
paying less for things that you know you
used to pay more for
um when we think about non-aid Goods so
things that unhcr and then wfp are not
producing but maybe are produced locally
the increase in demand from the shock in
the population will increase the price
so that if you're a net producer of
these Goods that will help you because
you can sell your Goods at a higher
price but if you're a consumer if you're
mostly just consuming these Goods that
increase in the price can hurt you so
it's not very clear up front how hosting
refugees is going to impact the economy
so we're going to try and tease out you
know which of these channels is
happening and and look you know at the
average of facts
so to do this we combine data from many
many different data sources so the first
thing we look at are so that we can get
a nice long-term View
we take data from Nighttime satellites
which are you know have been pretty
established in the literature as a good
proxy for economic activity and even in
a place like turkana you can observe
nighttime lights even though it is
isolated and Rural you do observe
nighttime lights at first we were like
maybe we're not going to see anything
but but you do
um so we have the GPS data points for
648 villages in turkana which we then
map to the nighttime lights data in each
year from 1993 to 2013. and we combine
that with data on the refugee population
in each year and so we're going to look
essentially at how far your village is
from the camp and over time as the
refugee population increases how does
the economic activity in your village
fluctuate we combine that data also with
some data from the Hunger safety net
program which was an unconditional cash
transfer program that was being rolled
out by the government of Kenya at the
time and it's a proxy means tested
program so they surveyed over 140 000
households to get information primarily
on consumption to see if they could
um you know if they were eligible for
the program and we have access to that
data so we can add a snapshot at least
cross-sectionally we can understand uh
you know consumptions of these
households again at distances that are
near to the camp and far from the camp
we also combine that with information on
livestock prices over time so there's
five key livestock markets in Kenya one
of which happens to be located in
turkana and we can look at how prices of
livestock fluctuates in those markets
over time as refugees
come in to the camp and then finally we
collect our own data from June to July
2015. we surveyed around 450 turkana
households so in the host population and
around 170 Refugee households so again
we have another snapshot of
cross-sectional data this time just from
within the camp and then around turkana
so we have two empirical strategies uh
that we will use to answer this question
the first is to just look at the
nighttime lights as a proxy for economic
activity and we look at whether the
effect of Refuge the refugee population
increasing is stronger for villages
closer to the camp compared to far away
from the camp and then we'll corroborate
this with our cross-sectional data both
from the hsnp the the cash transfer
uh survey again looking at consumption
close to the camp versus far away from
the camp and then also with our own
survey data that we tried to construct
in the best sort of counterfactual way
that we could which is we surveyed
households uh that were living in kakuma
town so not so hope something that's
important to notice that host families
they do not live in the camp they live
outside of the camp
um in pakuma town and around and then we
chose two what we call counterfactual
towns as our control towns and the way
that we selected these towns is that
they had to have a similar population to
kokuma in 1989 so prior to the arrival
of refugees and they were situated on
sort of the main artery that connects
catale which is a town in South Western
Kenya to Juba which is the capital of
South Sudan you know as a main artery
for the transport of goods and obviously
it's going to be important economically
so we picked towns that were about the
same size as kokuma that were situated
on this highway and then we stratified
our random sampling of these of these
households by their distance to the
center of the Town itself so here's a
map of the turkana region and here is
kakuma that's where the refugee camp is
located our first counterfactual town
is a town called lokichogio and actually
lokichogio is also going to be we're
actually going to use it not as a
counterfactual but as a placebo because
Loki chogyo is where initially all of
the NGO operations for the camp were
running and so we would think that
that's obviously an important place and
we can also see if you know you know if
there's something in particular about
just the ngos being there and creating
an economy just through the ngos or if
it's something specific to actually
having refugees which is where what
kakuma has
um our two counterfactual towns are Lord
which had a similar population to kakuma
in 1989 and is situated on this main
artery leading to Uganda and lokuchar
which again meets the same criteria and
is situated on this highway and
interestingly enough right before we
were in the couple of years before we
started collecting the data lokichar had
discovered oil and was always sudden
sort of booming economic economically so
this is also an interesting uh counter
factual place to study because it
obviously has economic importance
but it doesn't have refugees
so I won't bore you too much with the
estimating equation economists would
obsess over this but just in general
what we're doing is we're taking as our
dependent variable we have an index of
nighttime lights we take the inverse
hyperbolic sign which is essentially
like a log function because there is
skew in the data
um and we look at as our independent
variables we interact
the population of refugees living in the
camp in a particular year and we
interact that with how far away uh your
village is so we're taking the nighttime
lights in a particular Village so how
far away is your Village from the camp
itself and then we control for lots of
other things that vary over time at
across space so we control for the
distance to erode which is obviously
going to be very important
we control for Village fixed effects and
near fixed effects which allow us to
capture unobservable factors that don't
change over time so that's the village
fixed effect and things that macro
economic factors that change over time
with the year fixed effects
and what I'll show you next is a very
messy table but I will walk you through
it and panel a we parametrize our
dependent variable in in a few different
ways just to really check how robust our
estimates are and then we also look at
various different constraints on the
data so in panel a we're just using what
is the the log essentially of the
nighttime lights index
as a dependent variable and in the First
Column we look at our full sample of
villages uh in the second column we
restrict the sample to only Villages
that had a similar population to kakuma
so 5 000 people or more in 1989 and in
the third column we restrict our
villages to only Villages that ever
registered any positive nighttime light
activity ever in history and what we can
see is that you know the further away
from the camp you get and as the refugee
population increases the nighttime
lights index goes down or conversely the
closer you get the higher the night time
in the nighttime lights indexes and
that's what we're doing in columns four
through six is we just look at the
inverse of that as a measure of
proximity
in panel B and panel C we do other
things to account for the fact that
there are lots of zeros in our data so
in panel B we limit our analysis we use
a Tobit analysis which allows us to
account for the fact that we're
truncated at zero we get very similar
results so the closer you are to the
camp and the more refugees there are the
higher the nighttime lights indexes and
then in panel C we just use a linear
probability model which is a zero one
for do you have any nighttime lights
indexed at all and again very robust
results
what is I'd like to show instead of that
messy table is this beautiful picture
which basically tells tells the story
um
in in a picture so first in panel a what
we're looking at is we we take bins of
10 kilometers uh away from the camp and
we look at the average of the nighttime
lights in that bin as the as the refugee
population increases and you can see
really this effect is coming from
Villages that are within 10 kilometers
of the camp
um so a 10 increase in The Refuge
Refugee population is associated with
3.7 increase in the Luminosity index or
you know a proxy of economic activity
when we look at these counterfactual and
Placebo towns so in panel B we say okay
let's just assume that the camp was
located in lokichar and let's see what
the effect of the increasing Refugee
population is well there's no effect and
that's what we would expect right and
then in panel C what we're looking at is
this Placebo of lokichogio which is the
place where originally all the NGO
activity uh was occurring and what's
fascinating about this is first of all
you don't see any effect close to
lokachogio but when we look at the
distance bin that's associated with
kakuma you see the effect for kakuma so
this for us was was very reassuring to
say look there's something going on so
as more refugees come into the camp
economic activity is increasing over
time
what we then do is we take our
cross-sectional data and we just look at
consumption using the hsnp data at
distance bins to kakuma and again what
we find is that households that are
living within 10 kilometers of the camp
their consumption is 25 percent higher
than these other households that are
living farther away from the camp
so these two estimates allow us to
essentially do a back of the envelope
calculation and let us know what what is
the elasticity of consumption with
respect to Refugee inflows and that's
about 0.55 which is pretty high
um so you know a
with a 10 uh increase in in the refugee
population
we look at other
you know what are the mechanisms that
are potentially driving this result and
it appears that there are two main
mechanisms the first is that is through
the labor market
so in for households that live near to
the camp there's more employment in
low-skilled occupation so remember at
the time of the establishment of the
refugee camp there essentially was no
labor market for turkana people they
were just herding cattle essentially
um now presently there are people who
are living near the camp you know
working for unhcr and low-skilled
occupations as cleaners as Cooks as
drivers uh as you know greeting officers
when people come into the camp
um the other main uh channel that we
find is is through the livestock market
so and this is pretty intuitive when you
think about it so refugees get you know
a food Aid package from the wfp the
world food program and that consists of
flower oil beans and rice essentially
um but there's no meat and most of these
cultures eat meat and what do the
turkana has they have meat so there's uh
you know there's an exchange between
turkana producers who can sell their
meat in the main livestock market in
kakuma and Refugee households who are
capable who are able to to buy this meat
and so what we find is that uh the
livestock prices closer to the camp are
rising with the the influx of of
refugees
and so you know the takeaways from this
first paper realize that there's
considerable economic links between the
refugee and the host community in this
context and at least in this context
um which is one of the largest camps in
the world uh refugee camps do generate
some positive benefits for the local
economy and you know there's obviously
caveats we look at a particular camp in
a rural area this is not representative
of all camps but I would rep say
representative of many camps
um but obviously the effects are going
to be different in other settings I
can't say anything about what's you know
what are these effects going to be in
the U.S or in Europe or in Australia
um furthermore our counterfactual is not
perfect we did the best that we could
with the data that we had but it's not
perfect so I'm not necessarily claiming
that it's causal but it's highly highly
suggestive
um and what we are observing here are
average effects so we don't look at any
heterogeneity we can't do a cost benefit
analysis and say you know
the you know the the benefit of Hosting
refugees will be this much in GDP we
can't we can't say that but what we can
say is that you know there's a strong
link between the host and the refugee uh
community that that benefits both
so what we do in the second paper is we
exploit this natural experiment that
happened right as we were just getting
ready to collect the data for the first
paper
um there was I don't know if any of you
remember this but there was a terrorist
attack on garissa University College
which is in the north east of Kenya
um in April 2015 and al-shabab claimed
responsibility for that attack where you
know over a hundred people died and many
people were injured the Kenyan
government was obviously distressed and
um as a result expressed concerned about
the lack of oversight of money sending
agencies specifically what they were
calling Muslim transfers
um through through a transfer system
known as hawala so I'll get into the
details of koala in a minute but it's
essentially rude it's a money exchange
rooted in Islamic Finance
um and you know mostly limited people
who are using hawala are mostly Muslim
so the Kenyan government says all right
nope we're shutting down hawala because
this is funding terrorist activities and
so the Central Bank shut down all hawala
transfers starting in on April 8 2015
and reopened them again in June 20 uh in
June of 2015. so we were already
collecting our data we started to
collect our data in early June so we're
able to
um you know we ask households
retrospectively what was your
consumption before April and then you
know what is your consumption now and
we're able to try try and understand how
this shock to remittances may have
affected not only Refugee households but
turkana households as well
so so how does hawala work hawala is an
informal way of transferring money
between two people so essentially your
person a and you say I want to send
money to person B
um and I'm gonna do that by going to my
hawala dealer person X and you say Okay
I want to send my friend some money and
they the dealer says okay great how much
do you want to send them and what is the
password that they need to give to pick
up the money so you give them that
information the hawala dealer then goes
to their friend Hawaii dealer M who's
nearby to your friend and says okay
they're sending the money here's the
money
um
they don't actually exchange so the
dealers don't necessarily exchange money
directly right away this is an informal
transfer system based on the honor
System so at some point these people you
know these dealers will settle up
um but there isn't necessarily an actual
exchange of money at the time so it's
really based on the honor System and
trust and there's very there's no
interest
um there's no fees the fees are very low
because it follows Islamic financial
principles so then the dealer says all
right great I have the information your
friend comes in to pick up the money
they give the password they get the
money and that's how hawala works
in spite of its informalness there are
you know formal businesses so this is a
picture of the ham Shield which is the
largest hawala dealer uh I in Kenya
certainly
um so you know it is formalized
institutionally but it's really based on
the honor System you know and the fees
are really low
so the government of Kenya says all
right no no hawala transfers
um however things like Western Union and
you know other forms of mobile money
transfers who are still able to function
over this time so when we think about
how this shutdown could it could impact
uh first refugees you know obviously
there would be direct negative effects
on households who are previously using
remittances
um but there could be positive
externalities or positive you know
spillover effects on other households if
the decrease in purchasing from the
households were affected lower prices so
if you have a decrease in demand from
the households who can no longer buy
what they were buying this will push
prices down and if you weren't affected
this is positive for you because you can
buy things for cheaper
um but if you're a household that is
selling those goods you will be hurt by
those lower prices so again the effects
are kind of ambiguous or at least you
know heterogeneous and so we'll try to
exploit we'll try to look at this
heterogeneity in our analysis when you
think about turkana households or host
households there will be just like
producers Refugee producers or Refugee
seller good sellers there would be
negative effects on households who are
selling items to refugees if the demand
for those for those items Falls as a
result of their reduction in income
um but again if you're a household who's
consuming these Goods that have the
price lowered then you benefit from
having a lower price of consumption or
there could just be no effect on
households if you're if you're
uninvolved in markets at all you know in
some turkana households are not involved
in markets although as we established in
the first paper the the ones that live
around the camp certainly are involved
in markets
um
so to look at this we interviewed
hawaladeers so there are hawala dealers
inside of the camp
um that we were able to to interview and
get some qualitative information from
and then we also have the two household
surveys that we were conducting right at
the time of of the shutdown so we have
the refugee household survey which we um
conducted from June 9th to the 20th so
that the ban was lifted on the 22nd so
all of the refugees in our household we
interviewed while they were currently
um unable to access hawala uh the
turkana household was roughly the same
time we have a few households that were
um you know that we interviewed after
the ban was lifted but we asked a lot of
different information in the household
on their demographics on their
employment uh we had a consumption
schedule so that's largely what we'll
use to understand you know what are the
impacts and we asked households you know
what was your consumption like in the
first week of April versus at the time
of the survey so obviously a caveat is
that you know the the pre data we have
is retrospective
um but nonetheless we we do our best
so when we interviewed these hawala
dealers
um they tell us that the remittance
shutdown was complete it was it wasn't
forced they could not make any transfers
um when we talked to them about what
their transfers were like prior to the
shutdown they were enormous so
um the average monthly
transfers for the hob Shield was about
sixty thousand dollars USD
um when we look across these these five
dealers in the camp we know what they
report suggests that there's 2.4 million
USD in transfers occurring annually this
is enormous and this you know this
we there are other researchers who who
prior to the shutdown have have been
doing work on hawala in the camp and
this data is completely consistent with
what they have collected as well so I
mean this is an enormous amount of
economic activity that's occurring
and that was stopped for you know a
couple of months
um when we interviewed refugees what we
found is that 60 of refugees had
received remittances in the past year
the average size of the last transfer
was about two hundred dollars and they
receive around six transfers per year so
again this is a lot of economic activity
coming uh coming into the the camp you
know when you compare that to the GDP
per capita in Kenya which was around
fifteen hundred dollars USD in 2016.
this is this is significant
um 54 of remittances occur through
hawala this is largely due to the fact
that there's a huge Somali population
um in the camp who who are Muslim and
there are other smaller populations as
well
um but this is also as a researcher this
was nice for us because we have
variation so not everyone is receiving
hawala some people are receiving hawala
and we can exploit we can exploit that
heterogeneity to to really try and
understand the various channels
um
45 of the remittance receivers who we
interviewed they reported that they
experienced a decrease in remittances
since since the shutdown
so when we just look before and after we
just compare everyone in our Refugee
sample so 170 households we compare
their consumption in April to their
consumption in June with a simple t-test
we don't find any differences so there
was no change on average
but as I mentioned there's significant
heterogeneity in this population and so
if the first level of heterogeneity we
we look at is just did you do you
receive transfers or do you not receive
transfers
um and you can see regardless of whether
it's hawala
so you can see that you know
people whose language is you know we
didn't ask people what is your what is
your religion but we do we you know we
know the language that the interview was
conducted in and you know people from
Somalia nuba and Darfur are mostly
Muslim and so we use that as our proxy
sort of for how exposed to hawala would
you would you be you know and so people
who you know we think would be largely
most likely to use hawala and who had
received transfers previously there's a
big difference in their in their
consumption before and after
um and people who've been in the camp
longer were more affected you know had
had um
the lower consumption I'm sorry their
transfers were were affected
um but they actually
the people yeah their transfers were
affected sorry and people who have
household Enterprises uh were affected
so these are the business owners who are
probably using remittances to
um fund their businesses and again
people whose income was largely you know
a larger share of their income was
coming from businesses as opposed to
being employed or to selling animals uh
they also were affected by the shutdown
again these are just simple comparisons
of names so then we look again at
um those who used hawala specifically
and it's a similar pattern right so
people who are more likely uh to use
hawala were impacted
um people who said their transfers uh
they were people who use hawalo were
more likely to say that they they their
their transfers had decreased since
April
um they are less likely to be selling
animals so this is consistent with what
we would think of you know the
characteristics of people who would be
impacted by the shutdown
um then we try to estimate you know the
effect of this shutdown on consumption
for users and you know users compared to
non-users before and after the shock so
this is empirically something you know
similar to what we'd call a difference
in differences the only caveat is that
you know we don't have a whole panel of
pre-data we're really just looking at
these two periods one of which was a
retrospective uh survey but nonetheless
you know could be informative so what we
look at is your consumption in April and
in June
um and we regressed that on you know a
dummy for whether this was the June
period that you reported
um and then we interact that with
sources of heterogeneity so did you use
hawala in the past uh were you
interviewed in a language that you know
is associated with Islam
um did you or do you earn wages
primarily do you own a business
um and then we
sorry we include a household fixed
effect to control for unobservable
factors about the the household that
don't change over time
and what do we find so the first thing
we find is that for households who
received hawala in the past when we look
at their consumption in June compared to
their consumption in April what we find
is there's a decrease in some pretty key
um pretty key Goods which include milk
and meat which also happen to come from
things like cows and goats and sheep
that you know they're not producing the
the turkana households are producing so
already we sort of anticipate this might
have a spillover effect on onto the
local community
um and this this decrease in consumption
is pretty large so it's a 26 to 33
percent decrease in the consumption of
these goods for households that use
hawala
when we
um
when we look at households who don't
receive hawala that's what this
coefficient uh captures is that there's
actually an increase in the consumption
of these and these would be considered
luxury goods so things like sugar milk
and meat they don't come in the aid
package they're not things that people
eat every day normally you know they are
more expensive and so when you look at
households who didn't receive hawala and
you look at their consumption in June
compared to their consumption in April
we see an increase in the consumption of
these luxury goods so this suggests
there must have been some kind of price
impact on these Goods if you can
increase your consumption of them that
they're probably cheaper and that would
be driven by the fact that the huala
households have reduced their demand for
these Goods
um we run the same estimation just
looking at a different measure of hawala
exposure so instead of the direct
question do you use hawala we just look
at what language was the interview
conducted in and we find a very similar
effect here so households that speak
Somali nuba or darfuri are reducing have
reduced their consumption of milk and
meat in June compared to April
and we do still see you know at least a
positive increase for sugar in these
other other households
um then we look at more you know
heterogeneous
um impacts by the income source so were
you a wage worker
um did you own your own business and
again
um we still see we still use the
interaction of hawala so again we still
see this reduction in consumption for
hawala uh hawala households but we don't
really see an impact on wage workers or
people who who own businesses
so
then we look at you know we look at the
turkana households so was there we have
reason to believe there could be
especially you know with the reduction
of meat and milk there could be
spillover effects onto the Chicana
households particularly if they're
producing these things if they're
selling these these these Goods to the
refugees and so we leverage again our
our empirical strategy where we're
looking at households that are close to
the camp and far away from the camp
using those counterfactual towns I had
told you about before and we're looking
at their change in consumption between
April and June
um uh depending on whether they live in
the kakuma sample or if they are farther
outside of the kakuma sample and then we
also look at their heterogeneity by
their income Source are they producing
you know livestock or are they doing
other things are they more exposed to
this shock or not
um and what we find is that you know in
terms of things that we think would you
know confound this analysis their income
and assets between households who live
in kakuma versus don't live in kakuma
are basically the same you know so in
terms of wealth you know on average
these households are the same so we
would be concerned right if for example
households living near kokuma were just
poorer on average
um that would be that would suggest that
if we did find any effect it's just
because these households are poor we
don't have reason to believe that would
be poor in fact we we think they would
be richer because they're so linked into
this economy but you know on average
we find that they're basically the same
um but what we do find is if we look at
their consumption in June it's much
lower for the households that are living
near
comma
and we do find that they've reported
they've decreased their food consumption
they're morally more likely to have
decreased their food consumption uh over
time between April and June
so then we you know we estimate more
formally this impact and what we just
look at a simple uh regression is did
you you know what was the change in your
purchase of sugar and tea and milk these
you know more luxury goods if you're in
the kokuma sample your consumption
decreased for sugar and tea
um this is just if you purchased it on
the you know intensive margin it doesn't
seem like there's any effect but whether
you know external margin did you
purchase or did you not purchase you're
much more likely less likely to purchase
these things if you're living in kakuma
and then we look at the heterogeneity by
you know how exposed to this shock would
you be well if you're selling animals
you're going to be more exposed to this
shock because we already demonstrated
that the demand for these Goods
decreased and in fact we find that this
is really driven by you know households
who are selling animals
um and the probability of consumption
has decreased by you know 12 and 15 for
sugar and tea respectively
um you know so what we find here is that
on average refugees are not hurt by the
shutdown
um but you know the more exposed you
were to this shock
you know not surprisingly the the bigger
the effect so hawala receiving refugees
they reduce their consumption of key
Goods
um as a result of this shock from 23 to
29 including meat which you know they
buy from the turkana households other
groups were not as affected by this
shock
um and if anything non-hawala households
were positively affected by this shock
um through the through the reduction in
price of these Goods
um we find spillover effects to turkana
households particularly those who are
producing meat and milk and you know
these Goods that that hawala households
reduce their consumption of
um and so that results in a reduction of
you know the purchase of key luxury
goods sugar and tea by by the turkana
households and so you know I think the
main takeaway from this paper is that
things like you know blunt policies like
blockages to remittances they can they
can have a really negative effect
especially on the populations they
weren't intended to impact and so you
know we need to be thoughtful about
um how we approach these kinds of
policies
that's all I have for you today I'm a
little bit early but I hope that we can
have a nice discussion this is just a
picture that I took of a of a turkana
household
um outside of kakuma and it's it's
pretty representative of of their way of
life
um and yeah so I hope that you learned
something and I and I look forward to
our discussion
great thank you uh so much Sarah for
this um really engaging presentation
um so for those of you in the audience
um please feel free to use the raised
hand feature if you have any specific
questions
um or use the chat
um I'll exercise my privilege of going
first ask um so you know especially
given that this is uh
um you know kind of a more established
project and one that you're sort of you
know have kind of closed the book on I
wanted to ask you
um in particular for some of the
students in the audience to reflect a
little bit on the experience of doing
this research project so a few things
that are obviously striking this is a
very challenging area to do research um
in for a number of reasons
um so if you could talk a little about
your field work and and some of that one
thing that's really striking and really
lovely I think about the research in the
presentation is
um you know you're you're very
forthcoming about some of the
shortcomings but you do a lot of
creative things I think to get some
empirical leverage in places that I
think would be really hard to get like
that perfect identification strategy G
so I'd also love to hear a little bit
about your thought process how you kind
of develop those things
yeah thanks thanks for that Emily yeah
first I first I'll speak about the field
work so
um I mean I've done a lot of field work
in my life and this certainly was not
the first field work that I had ever
done but to this day Remains the most
challenging field work I've ever done I
mean first of all just the condition the
environmental conditions are very tough
so we were there in you know May June
and May June July and August uh which
are some of the hottest months it's very
arid it's very dusty it was just
physically varied and I wasn't even
conducting interviews I was just
managing the field team and going out
you know for a couple hours to check on
people and then debriefing at the lovely
Ethiopian restaurant
um and that in itself in itself was the
the most challenging work I've ever done
um you know environmentally but also
just it's you know it's a it's a the
difficult region politically in terms of
security so at the time we had to travel
with armed guards everywhere we went so
the I guess I should take an even bigger
step back and say this work would not
have been possible if it were not for
the support of the World Bank and unhcr
so essentially the way we came into we
didn't just rock up to the to the camp
and say hey we want to do some
interviews you know this kind of work
requires a lot of institutional support
so we were invited by the World Bank and
the unhcr to conduct the study and you
know the first paper
um resulted in a policy paper that the
World Bank has published and it informed
uh policy in Kenya about what they were
going to do with the camps so you know
to do this kind of field work speaking
to the students in the room to do this
kind of field work requires a a very
strong institutional partner and support
because otherwise it's not possible but
it's also not appropriate right so I
think you know there was a lot of
conversation between unhcr and the World
Bank
um and you know and local turkana
leaders so the very first thing that we
did when we arrived in turkana even
though we had the support of unhcr in
the World Bank we went to each of these
you know counter factual towns and we
met with the political leaders of those
towns introduced ourselves and said you
know here's what we're doing here's who
we're working with do we have your
support to work in your community and
that you know that
those were long conversations and you
know is it is the first step you have to
do when you when you conduct this kind
of field work
um you know and thankfully we got the
support but yeah I mean it was intense
it was intense and anytime we we
traveled to these uh these other towns
we we really were accompanied by armed
guards and that you know I have
certainly never I had never experienced
anything like that prior and I and I
haven't since so
um yeah it was it was hard
um
but then in terms of you know the the
empirical strategy you know I come you
know I have ones that in the development
economics world and I think as many of
you know that's the that's the world of
rcts and you know I've certainly done
rcts
um and they're appropriate for certain
questions but this is very clearly
something that you can't randomize and
you know not everything can or should be
answered with an RCT and so I think you
know what we said to ourselves is like
what how could we possibly piece
together
uh enough evidence that would be you
know highly suggestive of something so
that's why we said all right you know
obviously we can do things
cross-sectionally and so let's think
about empirically what are the types of
things that can confound any kind of
analysis unobservable or observable and
that's sort of how we came up with the
you know the counter factual uh towns in
our cross-sectional analysis and then we
said okay what how could we essentially
what we're trying to answer is a
long-term question but we only have a
snapshot of data so how could we
possibly you know get data that would
allow us to look at the these longer
term effects which you know then if if
you haven't worked with a nighttime
lights data I would encourage you to
look into it it's a really phenomenal
set of data and allows you to answer
questions even in very remote parts of
the world
um
so yeah I mean I think we're living in a
fortunate time of data where there's
just all of this data that's that has
become available to us and you know
that's both good and bad you have to be
smart and intentional with how you use
the data but I hope that you I've
convinced you that we were
yeah
great are there other questions I have a
few more if we
um
so if no one else has a question I guess
um one thing I wanted to invite Sarah to
do is talk about some of her current
work I know that's kind of involved in
sort of an econ history-ish Direction
but I'm also relating to migration and
also relating to I think some of the
reasons these really important questions
related to culture institutions history
that kind of actually get raised a
little bit especially in this sort of
longer term analysis that you do in this
um uh in this first paper
um so uh I'd be curious to know if you
see any uh sort of through line with
this earlier work to your current work
or you think of it as more of a
departure but it'd be great to hear
about some of your current projects as
well yeah I mean I would love to talk
about my current projects I'm super
excited about them I do you know I see
them so to back up what Emily's
referring to is at the moment I'm
working on a large project that was
funded by the Australian research
Council to understand uh you know the
Dynamics of racial violence in the
United States going back to before the
Civil War all the way up until today
and you know obviously migration is is a
part of that I'm not looking directly at
migration at the moment but you know
certainly conflict is at the root of
that project and I do see these two
um as being related uh certainly through
the long-term impacts that conflict can
have on a society and the protracted
situations that that it creates
um and so what I'm doing in that paper
is essentially trying to understand you
know how did the Civil War contribute to
uh protracted racial violence in the
United States and so you know we
Americans love to talk about the Civil
War and how it was the bloodiest war in
all of our Wars combined and you know it
was obviously a pivotal moment for race
relations in the United States it you
know ended the institution of slavery
and at least in the very early years
following the during Reconstruction
ushered in an era of progressive civil
rights that were mainly granted to black
men
and you know what I do in the paper
essentially is look at how did the
casualties that were sustained in the
Civil War so most it was only in the
South only white men fought in the
Confederacy and you know
nearly 25 percent of the young male
population white male population died
fighting in the Civil War and that had a
significant demographic effect on the
population so not only do you have a
balance in racial a shift in the balance
of racial power you know there's
relatively more black men than white men
who now have political rights and
economic rights that are you know for
some white Southerners perceived as a
threat to the social order but there's
also a shift in gendered power because
you have all these young white men who
are dying and now there's a what we
would call in Gross econ speak we would
say there's a surplus of white women or
there's this disruption to what we would
call the White marriage market so
there's a generation of young white
women who are unmarried they're either
widowed or they can't find Partners who
are their age because they have died in
the war more and so essentially what I'm
looking at is the intersection of these
two forms of power so you have a shift
in racial power and you have a shift in
gendered power and that creates a
perfect storm of racism and violence and
uh what I'm what we're finding in this
paper is that you know not only is there
an increase in racial violence in places
where the white male death rate was
higher
but there's a particular type of
violence so you know lynchings were you
know the main form of violence used
against black people for you know 100
plus years
um but in particular you know in about
40 of lynchings when you look at the
data the excuse given for the lynching
was that a black man had sexually
assaulted a white woman
you know and we know Ida B Wells was
working on this in the 1890s we know
that these are false accugee accusations
and she has a really famous quote saying
that you know if you look at four-fifths
of these accusations they would be
considered adultery and so what she's
insinuating is that actually these are
consensual relationships that were
happening between white women and black
men and you know because they were taboo
and bucked the the Norms of the social
order they were often uh called rape and
you know someone's father finds out that
his daughter is having an illicit
relationship and and tells her to claim
that she's been raped and you know this
justifies the lynchings and in fact To
Kill a Mockingbird is all about this so
you know this is a a an enduring
phenomena in our culture and uh you know
what our work is essentially showing is
that in these places where more white
men died in the Civil War you see an
increase in in racial violence but it's
primarily through this sexual channel so
you see you you only see more lynchings
using sexual excuses you don't see more
lynchings for murder or assault or or
arson or theft it's only using the
sexual excuse and then we combine that
with data from the newspapers that we
scraped keywords from from newspapers
which were highly localized at the time
and what we find is there's a narrative
in the places
where more white deaths happened in the
Civil War there's a narrative in the
newspapers that you know black men are
rapists essentially
and we see this you know not only we
actually don't see this during
Reconstruction so we're able we have a
very long-term set of data we're looking
from 1850 all the way up until today and
you know you don't see this narrative
happening during Reconstruction when the
South was occupied by federal troops but
as soon as reconstruction ends and as
soon as the Democrats which were not the
Progressive Party at the time are able
to run again for office you see more
support for the Democratic party and you
also see the the votes shift Republican
in the late 50s and 60s when the parties
shifted their policies toward race you
see this narrative being used in the
newspapers that's consistent all the way
up until
1930 which is where our data ends for
that and then when you look at the
implicit Association tests which I don't
know how familiar any of you guys are
with this but it's a test that Harvard
does online you should take it and it
gives you pictures of black and white
faces and good and bad words and you
associate these words with
um with faces
um we find actually no effect on
implicit bias but when you look at the
self-reported questions that respondents
are asked at the end of the survey there
is an association today among
respondents who are living in a place
that had a big shock during the Civil
War and their racial attitudes and
they're largely ones that are consistent
with this narrative so they're more
likely to think that black people are
violent they're less likely to want to
have a sexual relationship with a black
person they're less likely to want to
have a black roommate
they feel nervous and uncomfortable
around black people so yeah this is this
is still a work in progress and you know
we do have a we have a working paper
that's up on my website if you if you'd
like to read it we're in the process of
revising it but um yeah we're we're it's
you know an obvious tragic finding but I
think it's an important one for for us
to share and we're excited to be able to
share that
absolutely I will definitely um check it
out and uh and I think strangely it kind
of is a connection with this sort of
legacies of conflict legacies of
violence
um literature yeah yes any other
questions
in that case let me um thank again um
Sarah especially you know for being so
flexible at the time so we can all make
it um a large number of students I know
are also going to watch this on
recording so um I also like to thank you
for in addition to this great
presentation to being so candid about
sort of the experience of working in
this topic I think to me extraordinarily
valuable for people to hear
um and um we are looking forward to
seeing how this new research agenda
develops
great thank you so much Evelyn thank you
so much to the Center for having me this
has really been wonderful and please you
know for those of you who are watching
the recorded version or even watching
now like really feel free to reach out
I'm always happy to talk about my
research and would love to hear from you
thank you very much uh a pleasure to
have you here